نعم بحسب ما علمناه الان من فريق الانقاذ
الذي اشرف على العمليه شخصين تم انتشار
ثلاثه اشخاص شخصين بحاله جيده وطفل مريض
تم نقلهم اذا المجموع هو ثلاثه اشخاص كما
ذكرنا بينهم طفل لكن طفل مريض يبدو ان
حالته الصحيه سيئه لذلك تم نقلهم مباشره
الى مشفى هاتاي لتلقي العلاج العاجل كما
نتابع
وهنا ايضا هنا جثتين تم انتشالهما من تحت
الانقاذ
كما نتابع هنا ايضا حيث اقف الان
كما تتابع هنا ايضا تم انتشار جثتين من
هذا المكان
تم انتشال هاتين الجثتين من هذا المكان في
وسط هاتاي
وكما اخبرنا فريق الانقاذ من قرستان تم
انتشار ثلاثه اشخاص اثنين بحاله جيده وشخص
وطفل في حاله صحيه
سيئه نتمنى له الشفاء العاجل وان يتم تلقي
العلاج ان يتم اعطاء العلاج السريع ونقله
بسرعه الى
احد المشافي القريبه
نعم الان فرق الانقاذ عاده الى المكان
لاخذ المعدات ويتم ابعاد جميع الاشخاص
الذين ليس لهم علاقه بهذا المكان
بعيدا عن المكان
حقيقه اللحظات تحبس الانفاس الامل تقريبا
كان مفقودا في العثور على ناجين لكن بعد
صمود كبير كبير لهؤلاء الاشخاص العالقين
تحت الانقاض تم انتشالهم احياء كما نتابع
ثلاثه اشخاص بعد 296 ساعه بالضبط تم
انتشالهم احياء اذا بعد 296 ساعه تم
انتشار ثلاثه اشخاص احياء من هذا المبنى
في هاتاي
نعم وحسب ما اعلم الان احسب ما اخبرني احد
هذا المبنى كان مكون من خمسه طوابق طابق
ارضي واربع طوابق
في هذا المبنى باضافه الى الطابق الارضي
ان هذا مبنى مكون من خمسه طوابق هؤلاء
الاشخاص العليقين تم انتشارهم من الطابق
الرابع
بحسب ما اخبرنا احد الاشخاص هنا كانوا
يعيشون في الطابق الرابع هؤلاء الاشخاص